this boulevard in the heart of new delhi
has received a makeover built by the
british it houses famous buildings such
as this war memorial the road has been
renovated and renamed there's a new
statue of freedom fighter subhash
chandra bose these are not merely
cosmetic changes
the road was called king's way and was a
symbol of colonialism now it is called
path of duty king's way was for the
british empire for them we were slaves
now its architecture and spirit has
changed
india was a british colony for nearly
two centuries 75 years after
independence it's trying to shake off
that legacy
much of this part of the city was
designed by english architect edwin
luchan
today it's also a major tourist
attraction
wide roads are lined by the parliament a
palatial home for the president and
several museums the government is
removing what it calls symbols of
slavery it's also spending more than one
and a half billion dollars on revamping
this area opposite the old parliament a
new one is being built other plans
include a new home for the prime
minister
there are concerns about the
environmental impact and poor working
conditions at the site
the most significant change is the
underpass it's benefited locals tourists
everyone it's not so crowded anymore and
it makes the place more beautiful
i have heard a lot about
chandra boss fought for india he
deserves this grand statue i am very
happy to see it at india gate
historians say the project is part of
the government's broader political goal
they have been all the time trying to
project themselves as symbols of
nationalism
they they in fact
have a hyper nationalism i think their
ideology is not one of nationalism it's
not one of anti-colonial nationalism we
know that they did not play their
ancestors played no part in the freedom
struggle
although india is a member of the
commonwealth observing a day of mourning
for britain's queen elizabeth ii is a
decision that's evoked mixed feelings in
a nation where many are keen to rewrite
the colonial past pavli mithal
al-jazeera new delhi